I'm told that our own Andy Richter has
been working on a new comedy bit for the
last couple of weeks and he says earlier
today he came at me said can I try it
out tonight and I thought sure why not
are you ready Andy I'm ready Conan are
you ready Allen in the booth I am Andy
all right
okay Andy go ahead remember this could
you stop a second what's wrong you're
not you're not doing a really a comedy
piece all you're saying is remember this
and then and then just showing pictures
of stuff well yeah that's just the setup
I mean you kind of ruined it
it changes oh I'm really I'm really
sorry I cut you off then I tried
inpatient I'm very sorry go ahead just
do it again yeah fine
Menahem remember
but them okay wait a minute could you
stop again Andy you just changed member
this to member him and member her that's
all you did
come on Conan it's a trip down memory
lane it's harmless and they like it
right
anybody that's so stupid anyone can do
that Alan will give me a screen I'll do
it to remember this
remember this
remember this okay
take it down take it down those who are
awful
yeah and we're terrible not so easy is
it that was that's not fair Andy that's
not fair I'm trying to do a comedy show
now the crowds upset they they're angry
with me
well okay I I think I can help remember
this
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please